our next presenter now this is actually
kind of exciting I want to let you guys
know our next presenter and I have been
looking for a project to do together for
a really long time and she claims this
is it so ladies and gentlemen Academy
Award nominee Reese Witherspoon
we all go to the theater looking for
movies to carry us away hoping to enter
a world we have never imagined we got to
visit three strange different and
enchanted worlds in this year's nominees
for Best Animated Feature they are
Howl's Moving Castle Hayao Miyazaki Tim
Burton's corpse bride Mike Johnson and
Tim Burton Wallace & Gromit
in the curse of the were-rabbit Nick
part and Steve box
and the Oscar goes to wallace and gromit
in the curse of the where rabbit Nick
Park and Steve I this is the first
Academy Award a nomination for Steve box
the fifth nomination and forth Oscar win
for Nick Park
oh this is like actually we've got a
little finger yes - nice the old bowties
for coordination we just happened to
bring them along yes in case just when I
give a great big thank you to Helena
Bonham Carter and particularly to Peter
Salas who has been the voice of Wallace
he's here tonight ladies and gentlemen
at the Oscars who's this he's being the
voice of Wallace for the last 23 years
and you've been an absolute gem Peter
and you've sparkled all the way also
thank you to Jeffrey Katzenberg and
DreamWorks who also Sparkle and there's
been a great support to this very
personal form of ours and just the whole
crew back in Bristol England at Aardman
Animations thank you so much you're
great and a little message from Steve
somebody once said if you make a bad
film you make it alone if you make a
great film everybody made it with you we
all made it together guys cracking T's
wrong mate